for 30 years scientists have been
looking at this Rogue protein called
amyloid that builds up in the brains of
people's world with Alzheimer's disease
and for those 30 years they've really
struggled to find a drug that does
anything to that protein but now they
have one that really works in this trial
the the amount of protein reduced so
much that the patients wouldn't have
actually had a formal diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease after 18 months of
treatment and that had an impact on
their clinical symptoms too it reduced
the mental the the progression the
decline in mental agility and memory
that you associated with with
Alzheimer's by 27 and that is hugely
significant the first time that they've
been able to show that and doctors are
optimistic that with longer treatment
that clinical benefit would become more
significant it's not a cure but this
does slow the progression of Alzheimer's
for the first time and allows patients
to spend more time with their families
of course and when will it be available
on the NHS or is that too early to say
well this is really important because
this is going to be a massive challenge
for the NHS at the moment most patients
are diagnosed too late to have this drug
and also the the number of brain scans
called pet scans and also lump lumbar
punctures these are biopsies of the
spinal fluid that are needed to
accurately diagnose Alzheimer's disease
are only given to just one percent of
patients so this is going to need a
revolution in the NHS to actually
deliver but we've been here with
multiple sclerosis in the past with the
treatments that are now available for
that disease and doctors are optimistic
that with some forward planning they can
do the same here it is an expensive drug
this lecanumab but it's worth it in the
long run they say because it would save
on expensive social care okay and when
might it be available I mean obviously
people listening this morning will think
that straight on the phone to the GP
saying I want that drug
yeah
look it's a really important question
Kate and this is a phase three trial now
the the drug company thinks that it's
going to apply for a drug license in the
US early next year and then follow up
with licenses here in the UK and in
Europe that could happen next year too
it takes a while for them to look at the
pros and cons of treatment and this drug
did have side effects it's important to
stress that that the potential for brain
bleeds so they need to make sure that
they've got good monitoring in place to
make sure patients can benefit from this
but hopefully it would be here used in
two or three years but again I have to
stress this is just for mild cases early
stage Alzheimer's disease and the NHS
needs to really ramp up to make sure
that patients do have good access to
this drug and finally and just develop
your point there um Thomas we must say
that people have died during these
trials haven't they
yes and you know the the side effects
are are really something that they are
concerned about and they think it's
because these clumps of protein of the
road protein when they're removed from
the brain it does really result in brain
swelling and potentially brain bleeding
so it does need careful monitoring but
in terms of deaths it was about the same
number of people who died in the
treatment group as those who were given
the dummy drug so they have to be looked
at very very carefully to make sure that
this can be caught at an early stage but
one doctor said uh last night if his if
he offered this drug to most patients
they would be happy to take this drug
because uh the the the benefits are so
great compared to the risk this is such
a devastating fear disease of old age
that most people would take this drug
and run that risk